[Musique]
xavier bertrand valérie pécresse ou
encore laurent wauquiez se sont
largement imposés de quoi renforcer les
ambitions présidentielles des trois
présidents de région je suis vraiment
très heureux de leur victoire de la
victoire de laurence valérie et aussi de
l'ensemble des sortants et de la droite
républicaine
moi je reste intimement convaincu que la
droite républicaine et populaire 7
telles quelles réponses aux problèmes du
pays
est-ce que depuis hier bruno retailleau
la droite à un candidat naturel
y a pas de candidat naturel toujours pas
y a pas de candidat naturel regarder on
a des candidats qui se sont bien placés
xavier bien sûr mais aussi valérie mais
aussi le rang wauquiez qui fait le
meilleur score
donc je crois qu'il va falloir se
trouver une méthode de départage
n'arrête pas de lien
ça vous fait déjà sourire le fait que le
président de la république dans les
derniers temps est voulu aller dans un
certain nombre de villes ce qui est
apparu comme tactique et non pas comme
une volonté sur le fond d'avoir ce
contact avec les français a pu jouer
dans un sens plutôt négatif c'est vrai
que la victoire a été belle parce que
finalement nous nous sommes battus en
ile-de-france contre trois fronts y
compris hier soir que le match à 3
c'était surtout bertrand pécresse
wauquiez si j'ai bien compris les
commentaires et les discours des uns et
des autres au soir de cette élection
moi je vais vous dire j'ai trouvé qu'il
y ait beaucoup de triomphalisme et j'ai
trouvé acpg entendu assez peu de propos
sur les sujets qu'on a évoqué un instant
et notamment l'abstention massive dans
la région grand est
j'ai vu qu'il y avait moins d'un tiers
des votants 30% de participation
le vainqueur a fait 40 % des voix donc
ce qui veut dire que le président
sortant a priori très populaire a été
élu par à moins de 10 % du corps
électoral qui en plus sont très
majoritairement des vieux un président
de la république en visite chez renault
pour le lancement d'une future usine de
batteries électriques dans le nord qui
vient féliciter un président de région
tout juste heureux
félicitations emmanuel macron s'installe
au volant d'un prototype électrique
siglé pour l'occasion présidence de la
république
une fois le cortège passe et s'assied au
même endroit xavier bertrand photo
postée illico sur les réseaux sociaux
par son équipe de communication vous
dirai à la fin de l'été si vous êtes
candidate à la présidentielle ou pas
absolument à la fin de l'été je vais y
réfléchir pendant l'été mais je vais
compliqué je vais réfléchir je vais
continuer dans un entretien aux échos
xavier bertrand frappe fort ce matin
avec macron la guerre est déclarée
depuis un moment explique-t-il
après avoir battu le rassemblement
national il se présente comme le
troisième homme et attaque emmanuel
macron la tambouille politique ne
remplace pas la politique même être
sympa sur le terrain ne remplace pas les
résultats
regardez ses affiches de campagne on a
pu voir fleurir un peu partout ce matin
en ile de france notamment
zemmour président pas n'importe où sur
des panneaux électoraux
c'est important ça manque quand on
investit on y arrive et on pas dit
beaucoup de choses suis pas dans une
course de vitesse mais je suis dans une
sérénité
il n'y a pas d'avenir pour la politique
ni au niveau local ni au niveau national
si on bascule dans une espèce de course
de petits chevaux de bois ou à peine on
a sauté mais on passe à une autre on va
tous en tirer les conséquences mais je
trouve que j'étais content devant aussi
en sambre avesnois terefe les chiffres
le résultat et qui montrent que quand on
réinvestit quand on a senti qu'on a fait
ces dernières années faire reculer la
colle on arrive à qu'elle met beaucoup
de choses nous sommes sans doute les
mieux préparés pour pouvoir mettre sur
sur pied et on est en droit du travail
et du reste mais aussi proposer à nos
concitoyens si c'est nécessaire
une dose supplémentaire qui atteindra
les composants pour lutter contre contre
inconnu troisième dose oui on sera prêt
à la rentrée